well we're in radio nottingham as you
can see and uh they've today announced
the the nobel prize for physics so in a
nutshell it's it's gone for black holes
it's the only way i could describe it
and in fact the wording of the citation
is kind of interesting so let me just
read it out it says the nobel prize in
physics 2020 was divided one half
awarded to roger penrose for the
discovery that black hole formation is a
robust prediction of the general theory
of relativity
the other half jointly to reinhard
genzel and andrea getz for the discovery
of a supermassive compact object at the
center of our galaxy
and you'll notice it sort of skates
around
saying anything there being about there
being a massive black hole at the center
of our galaxy
because technically no one has really
proved that that's what it is it's just
all you know no one can think of
anything else that it could possibly be
at this point the two astronomers they
you know been looking at the black hole
the center of our galaxy
basically what they they were looking at
they managed to establish that there was
a really compact object there four
million solar masses in basically a
region the size of our solar system or
even less and you know the remarkable
astronomical observations
but the guy i want to talk about is the
other half of the prize which is uh sir
roger penrose because i'm a theorist and
he's a theorist and so obviously we
share a lot of interest um and the work
that he did
and the reason that uh penrose got the
prize
uh was really he basically sort of
learned taught something about
the structure of black holes and what
lurks inside them and what lurks inside
a black hole is this dreaded singularity
this is this region of sort of uh
infinitely strong gravitational field
infinite uh space-time curvature that
horrible word infinity that basically
that these this horrible monster at the
center of a black hole exist so i would
say it's you know that 1965 paper that
remarkable paper which showed that these
singularities are for real and it really
shocked the world of physics everybody
was stunned by it no one saw it they
thought these singularities were just a
an artifact of symmetry they didn't
think they were real penrose showed that
they were real general relativity
generally
really did predict them and then you
know hawking then took that on and
worked with penrose as well and they
showed that you get these singularities
you know in a sort of at the big bang
either started the universe or maybe at
the end of the universe it wasn't just
inside black holes so the whole story
sort of sort of blossomed into something
and the other thing it tells you these
singularities tell you is that general
relativity is not a complete theory
because it can't describe those
singularities it's outside even though
even though it predicts they exist and
penrose showed us that you know you
follow your nose and follow general
relativity you're going to end up in
this place with these dreaded
singularities actually it can't really
describe it and that's why we know we
need more than general relativity we
need a quantum theory of gravity
whatever that might be string theory or
whatever so it also tells it also sort
of spelled the demise of general
relativity we know it's not the full
story just one of the other wonderful
things about what penrose did this is a
great piece of it it's a fabulous piece
of work as i said it's probably the most
important uh paper in in gravity between
einstein's original papers and his in
1965 but you don't really see nobel
prizes in the past given for these kind
of theory papers
um no one's actually gone into a black
hole and spotted a singularity that
hasn't happened and yet they've given
him this prize and i think it marks a
bit of a change for um for theorists and
potential nobel prize winners and i
think it's a great thing i absolutely
applaud it so uh long may this continue
and maybe is uh once again uh sir
roger's gonna be a bit of a trailblazer
for everybody else well so it's really
all about showing that there's a very
massive object at the center of the
galaxy
and in principle showing
measuring the mass of something showing
that there is a massive object somewhere
is reasonably straightforward in
astronomy in that for example
we know that the sun's at the center of
the solar system not just because you
know it glows in the sky but actually
because it holds all the planets in
orbit around it and so actually even if
the sun weren't giving out any light at
all we'd be able to say there's a
massive object in the center of the
solar system and actually we'd even be
able to say what its mass was just by
studying the orbit of the earth and the
other planets around it
so in principle you can sort of do that
make that kind of measurement for
anything which is gravitationally bound
together and in essence that's what
they've done for the center of the milky
way in that they've been looking at the
stars orbiting around the center of the
milky way and showing that the orbits
they're following imply that there's a
very massive object at the center of the
milky way it sounds very simple the way
i say it there
of course in practice it's a huge amount
more complicated and in part that's
because so it's part in part it's
because you're looking at something
which is pretty small in that the whole
of the region that they're looking at
where those things are all orbiting
around are all within an arc second or
so
and that's the scale on which if you
just take a picture of a star
with a telescope from the ground
typically the atmosphere blurs out the
image to about an arc second
so actually all those stars packed in
with those central arc seconds if you
just took a naive picture of the center
of the galaxy with the telescope they
will be blurred together and you
wouldn't actually be able to see
anything at all and follow their motion
the other complication is that the
center of the milky way is a very
difficult place to see
because between us and the center of the
galaxy there's a huge amount of merc
there's this stuff that astronomers
refer to as dust it's sort of this [ __ ]
smoky material which obscures our view
of the center of the galaxy which
essentially means that
very little of the light coming from the
center of the galaxy gets to us if you
look in the optical part of the spectrum
it's something like you know one photon
in 10 billion emitted near the center of
the galaxy actually gets to it so
there's no chance of actually seeing it
the solution to both of these problems
actually came along sort of in the 1990s
when um
astronomers started first making images
decent images in the infrared part of
the spectrum so it's sort of technology
driven that we started getting the the
detectors that allow us to make images
uh in the infrared part of the spectrum
where previously we'd really only been
able to make optical images and the
infrared has two big advantages firstly
that that merck is more or less
transparent so instead of sort of one
photon in 10 billion getting through
it's something like one photon in five
gets through so still a fair amount of
it gets obscured by the dust between us
and the center of the galaxy but
actually enough gets through that you
can start making images the other big
advantage of the infrared is it's more
straightforward to take out those
blurring effects of the atmosphere to
sharpen up the images
and so a lot of the
the breakthroughs in this area have come
because adaptive optics these techniques
that astronomers use to take out the
blurring effects of the atmosphere work
well in the infrared part of the
spectrum so they've really been able to
sharpen up those images so instead of
seeing those 20 or 30 stars near the
center of the galaxy all blurred
together into a single splodge they
really can make pictures of the
individual stars
and that has enabled them to monitor
those stars and actually literally see
them orbiting around the center of the
milky way apparently around nothing
there's nothing very much there well
there's a radio source there so there's
something there that we thought was a
bit suspicious and there's something
that gives out radio waves um but
there's not there's no obvious star
there or anything bright there
and these stars near the center of the
galaxy are all following these nice
elliptical orbits just like the planets
around the sun whizzing around something
which doesn't appear to be there
and now they've been able to observe
them for long enough that some of those
stars they've actually seen them go
around their complete elliptical orbits
now that gives you a very strong
constraint on okay i can actually
measure i know what the pull of gravity
has to be to be making things orbit
around the center
of the galaxy at that speed and that's
how they come up with this number of a
supermassive object in that central
region of the milky way of a few million
times the mass of the sun
so it's called the singularity the black
hole singularity
where penrose entered the game was he
wrote this paper in in a in 1965 which
basically shocked the world of physics
and basically what penrose showed was
that this singularity was likely to was
there okay that it was predicted by
general relativity so what happened
previously is people like oppenheimer
and schneider
had been looking at things like sort of
collapsing uh you know spherically
symmetric collapsing sort of clouds of
dust and shells and things like that and
in these very symmetric scenarios
they were seeing it as that those those
symmetric sort of distributions of
matter
collapsed in that indeed you would form
a black hole and at the center of that
black hole would be one of these dreaded
singularities
and people were like all right we're not
taking that seriously that's it's just
because you were considering a situation
with an awful lot of symmetry
that's the only reason that weird
singularity that weird infinity that
madness is there
but what penrose showed was it wasn't
really at account of this symmetry it
would always be there okay that this was
really an artifact of general relativity
that black holes do contain these
singularities okay he proved these
singularity theorems and it was much
more general it didn't require symmetry
it was extremely general statement all
you had to say was basically as long as
i have effectively positive energy if
i'm thinking about matter that's made up
of positive energy then i'm guaranteed
then it collapses to form black hole i'm
guaranteed to get one of these
singularities which basically is just an
end of space or an end of time
it's one of those things that kind of
crept up on the field in that you know
back in the 1960s people started
discovering these things called quasars
which were these incredibly bright
distant objects
which were varying on time scales of
days or at least you know weeks and
months as well um which tells you they
have to be very small right for
something to vary very quickly
you know if you actually had a whole
galaxy's worth of stars even if you
found some way of switching them all off
and on
because of the amount of time it takes
light to travel just from one side of
the galaxy to the other you wouldn't see
the whole thing switching on and off
very quickly so when you see something
varying on time scales of say a few
months that tells you it can only be a
few light months across so these quasars
were varying on very short time scales
which told you they were very small and
they were also incredibly bright
and this combination of things people
were casting around trying to figure out
could they be super massive stars or
various other ideas were thrown around
but the the idea that one out is that
had to be a very very massive object and
material was falling into it and you
were seeing the kind of the energy that
was liberated as the material fell into
it and that would both give you a lot of
energy because if the thing's very
compact the pull of gravity is very
strong so the stuff falls in extremely
fast and you have a lot of energy but
it's all in a very small region so it
varies very quickly so that was you know
as i say back in the 1960s
1970s people were starting to think
about it
in the 1970s this radio source at the
center of the milky way sagittarius a
star which is where this black hole is
located was found and that got people
thinking well maybe there's one in the
middle of the milky way as well
with the advent of the hubble space
telescope in the 1990s we were for the
first time able to actually start
um
resolving
regions close enough to the center of
other galaxies to see actually yes stars
are whizzing around extremely fast there
as well so it's one of those things that
kind of crept up on us a bit at the time
um
but this is sort of you know this is the
the the best measurement we have the
ultimate measurement and actually at
some level you know knowing it's there
in our own galaxy tells us quite you
know quite how commonplace this is that
even an ordinary galaxy like ours has a
massive black hole in the middle of it
what did penrose actually show
he showed that that the space time
wasn't complete inside the black hole
and what he said was wasn't geodesically
complete now what's a geodesic geodesics
are the sort of shortest paths in space
time they're the paths that a particle
will take if it's if it's not
accelerating through space time it'll
follow a shortest path now
assuming you were immortal and you could
in principle live for as long as time
could exist
you would just follow geodesics forever
okay you just go on and on and on and on
and on right what penrose showed was if
you fall into a black hole
and you follow one of these geodesics
eventually the geodesic itself will
grind to a halt and think about what
that really means that means there's an
end to either time or space there's
actually an end to time or space so even
though you might think you're immortal
nothing can destroy you
well the end of time can destroy you so
if you're falling into one of these
black holes you're following one of
these geodesics depending on the nature
of the geodesic you will start to feel
very strong gravitational fields you'll
start to feel yourself being ripped
apart by the tides of gravity literally
you know the atoms in your body being
torn apart and then
you know as you sort of beg for mercy
you know even if you're capable of
begging because your ass will be torn
apart as you beg for mercy what you'll
find is is that you'll be given that
mercy because time itself
or possibly space but in the case of um
depends on the nature of the black hole
but time itself will end okay so even
though you think you're immortal well it
doesn't matter because there is no more
time time itself stops and that's what
penrose showed that these things are
really lurking there inside black holes
we talked about these stars orbiting
around very close to the center of the
milky way they're still you know so this
one particular star s2 which is the one
that's gone closest to the center and
that's one that they've now followed
around a full orbit and in fact it got
so close you remember if you think about
elliptical orbits uh
like comets in the solar system for
example when they're kind of in their
outskirts of their orbits they travel
very slowly and then they whiz past the
sun and then back out again it's just
the same story here the stars hang
around
and then when they're close to the black
hole they whizz past it and then slow
down when they're traveling away from it
the one that went closest to the um to
the black hole at the center of the
milky way was traveling at about two and
a half percent of the speed of light so
it was actually a decent fraction of the
speed of light
and got sufficiently coast there's all
sorts of interesting things you can do
with it for example it was sufficiently
close to the black hole that the light
escaping from it not only had to escape
from the star but had to escape from the
gravitational field of the black hole as
well and so they were able to measure
that gravitational redshift the energy
that the light lost as it was escaping
from the region of the black hole
but even in these cases we're still you
know we're still the the distance i
think it was a hundred or so
astronomical units from
the
the
putative black hole in the center of the
milky way um so sort of a hundred times
the distance of the earth to the sun
which is about a thousand or so times
this thing called the short shield
radius which at some level is sort of
the size of the black hole it's that
point of no return where even light
can't escape so the sort of the size of
the black hole was a thousand times
smaller than the scale that this star
was probing
so we can't actually say we can say
within a thousand times the size of a
black hole was the mass of a black hole
but for it to actually be definitely a
black hole we have to be able to say you
know within one times the size of the
black hole there's that much mass but
actually we can only say it's within a
thousand times that region
there is nothing else that anyone could
think of that would pack that much mass
into that smaller region that wasn't a
black hole
but that's why they sort of hedged their
bets that tiny bit in the sanitation by
just saying this there's the huge amount
of mass in this very small region rather
than saying there is a black hole there
i mean the mass of the of whatever is
there is incredibly accurately
determined i have to look up the number
now but it says i think the best
measurement of it is it's 4.15 plus or
minus
0.01 million solar masses
so that's an incredible you know by
astronomical standards usually in
astronomy we're happy if we get
something within a factor of two right
so actually you know measuring something
to that level of precision is incredible
that they know very accurately how much
master is there they just don't know
for sure that it's all compressed within
a region small enough that it has to be
a black hole um so as i say it almost
certainly is there's nothing else that
anyone could think of that would explain
it
but they haven't in that sense seen a
black hole in the same way that for
example the event horizon telescope was
able to actually image very close to a
black hole itself they're actually
looking at a slightly larger region
which is telling you how much mass is
there and it's all very concentrated but
it doesn't in itself tell you for
certain that there's a black hole there
they were very much in competition with
each other so there were two groups in
the world so guetz working at ucla ucla
in california was using the keck
telescopes in hawaii and genzyl was
working in germany and using the
european southern observatory telescopes
in chile um so they really were sort of
in competition and it's one of those
sort of healthy competitions i don't
think it was you know it wasn't they
weren't um
unpleasant towards each other it's just
one of those things that was an exciting
thing that sort of occurred to both of
them at the same time they both started
working on it at more or less the same
time
um
and they've sort of both been competing
to get the results out
which is both healthy and that it's sort
of competition it drives us on to do
things better um but also it's sort of
healthy to have that cross-check because
if it was only one person in the world
was claiming they'd found something you
know you always think you know could
they possibly have made a mistake
somewhere along the line
so it's good to have two completely
different groups using different
instrumentation and potentially
different techniques for analyzing their
data and so on both arriving at
essentially the same conclusion we have
one corner of the penrose institute and
we had the first um
sort of ignore inaugural workshop of the
penrose institute took place right here
in nottingham a couple of years ago and
he was here for an extended period and
drank and we had a cup of coffee in the
in the library there and taught for you
know a long time about physics he also
gave us some lectures which were
fabulous and and the remarkable thing
about it was this is a guy who's well
into his 80s and these lectures were
going on for like two hours and his
stamina was was astonishing i first met
him sort of
well it's probably about 10-15 years ago
now and
i was a postdoc in oxford and and he was
he was actually retired by that point um
but there's
this this idea he'd had in in a sort of
late 60s early 70s twisters
suddenly came back into fashion and and
he came out of um
retirement to give us all some lectures
on it
and uh
what i remember about those lectures was
i mean they were fabulous but what i
remember most about them was how good he
was at drawing pictures he would draw
these pictures in the lectures and they
were just awesome it's like oh great
he's not just a great mathematician a
great physicist he's great he's a great
artist as well so it seems so that was
one thing that stuck my mind about about
those early days of meeting roger
penrose but obviously he's a legend of
physics on maths and
it's been a privilege to have been in
nottingham and it's great that he's won
the nobel prize
that poses a few problems i'm sure you
can imagine one of them is the fact that
as you tip the mirror through the night
to look at different angles of the sky
gravity starts to affect the mirror and
deform it ever so slightly
so what you do is you have something
called active optics which are
see all those little pistons there
there's 150 actuators
basically little pistons that can push
and pull